welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with the global
hunger crisis triggered by the war in
ukraine on friday the united nations
world food program called for ports in
southern ukraine to be reopened in order
to export the country's surplus of grain
needed to feed millions of people around
the world the u.n estimates that the war
could cause the number of humans facing
acute hunger to rise by 47 million to
323 million worldwide ukrainian farmers
meanwhile are facing far more problems
than where to send their harvests chris
livesay reports
if an army marches on its
stomach then ukraine's farms have never
been more vital and more of a target
the piglets and cavs were screaming says
lubov's labina they were burned alive
wheat fields have become battlefields
many farmers trading in their pitchforks
for rifles as russian forces are said to
be trucking away tons of ukrainian grain
insulting the earth they leave behind
what's the risk if you were to
cultivate that land right now
it could mean death for me and my
workers
north of kiev andre kurotkov runs the
last operative farm within 30 miles do
you think that they're trying to use
hunger as a weapon
i've seen it with my own eyes he says
they've bombed our storehouses and when
they leave they steal everything they
often cut the electricity and the water
supply too now some 45 percent of
ukrainians worry about finding enough to
eat according to the world food program
karatkov says it's the same tactic of
the infamous 1933 famine when stalin
starved millions of ukrainians by
cutting off their food
this time it's also the world's food
ukraine provides tens of millions of
tons of wheat and corn globally now cut
to a trickle by russia's invasion by
land and blockade by sea but the farming
must go on
some suiting up with body armor in order
to feed the country
we go out past the checkpoints get to
work drink tea and coffee put on our
vests and go says yuri
others seen on social media use their
tractors to capture abandoned russian
armored vehicles low-hanging fruit left
by soldiers low on morale
such acts are nothing short of heroic
says kharatkov as his country fights
tooth and nail
my biggest worry is for human life my
own family
for ukraine to be free so our children
and grandchildren are by our side he
says
like so many warriors
he's met his breaking point
what's your message to the russian
soldiers who are currently
on this land
that none of them go home alive he says
and our heroes come home to their
families
for cbs saturday morning chris lives say
keeve